على كل حال سالنا الناس في مصر اين تجد
السعاده الحقيقيه نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
سعد الحقيقيه في وجود زوجي وابني ووالدتي
طبعا سعاده الحقيقيه في ان انا اركز مع
اهدافي اكتر
وانما ابعد عن اي حاجه بتضايقني يعني اقدر
ان انا اخد القرار الملاحظ ان الحاجه دي
مضايقاني لا لازم ابعد عنها واخد القرار
يعني بلاقي السعاده الحقيقيه لما احيانا
لما بكون لوحدي واحيانا لما بكون قاعد مع
اصحابي بس يكون صحابي انا بحبهم صاحب
في الاهل في
لمه جميله نعمل اي
حاجه حتى لو ان انت تراضي طفل او تطعم
حيوان في في ربنا سبحانه وتعالى في الصلاه
في
التسبيح في الذكر في قراءه القران فلما
اكون عندي اهداف وانجح في الحقيقه ساعتها
بلاقي السعاده في راحه البال في الرضا
في الاقتناع بما هو حاصل او مقدر بصراحه
ايه بالنسبه لي النجاح
اللي انا عايزاه سواء بقى في شغل في
علاقات في ايا كان هي ايه المهم ان انا
انجح